green pepper also will you make me the
happiest man to walk dessert will you
marry me
nearly six months after Brandon Jones
and Serene Russell got engaged on
Bachelor in Paradise the two are calling
it off I'm like okay let's move on to
the next like what's next it's like no
let's like live in the moment the
reality stars shared their ending their
relationship in a joint statement which
included pics and videos of them
together
[Applause]
[Music]
Brandon and Serene write that they've
tried to work privately on their
relationship but it's been incredibly
challenging in the public eye quote this
has been immensely hard to accept and
painful as there is a lot of love
between the two of us and we're really
excited
I think right now we're just really
focused on like enjoying this season of
Life on season eight of Bachelor in
Paradise Brandon and Serene became the
fan favorite couple from the start
Serene is absolutely insanely beautiful
you know I'm here to find my person I
don't want to waste time you got like
the I want to kiss you eyes
and something that really set him apart
is he was so intentional and that was
something I said I needed from the gym
and that strong connection led to their
Seaside proposal I feel like we have two
hearts cut from the same cloth and I've
never felt more seen
or understood in my entire life it was
like every day I felt a little more in
love and you know just seeing that like
we align on so many different like
things it's like I realized he was my
soul mate a little bit at a time and
that's like one of the many things I
love about her is like yo like these big
milestones we get to celebrate and like
we're not overlooking him in their
statement Brandon and Serene add they're
deeply hurting and ask there be no hate
the best path forward for us at this
time is to try and move forward and heal
from this as individuals
[Music]
thank you